stress fatigue isolement ou encore vie
personnelle en suspens le quotidien des
aidants professionnels est devenu une
vraie problématique de la maladie
d'Alzheimer ainsi indirectement
aujourd'hui 3 millions de personnes sont
concernées par la pathologie en France
les 2/ers des patients vivent à domicile
euh dont un/ers quand même dans un état
dans une un état sévère quand même donc
beaucoup à domicile et donc c'est les
aidans c'est grâce aux aidans qu'ils
peuvent rester à domicile hein c'est la
famille qui les entoure un aidant qui
est soutenu ça change beaucoup parce que
indirectement ça euh ça joue sur le le
patient et pour évoquer justement les
difficultés des aidents de nombreux
événements étaient organisés dans les
structures médico-sociales et notamment
à l'hôpital de plaisirgrigon pour la 2e
année consécutive notre filière qui est
composée d'un hôpital
euh qui fait médecine aigu et SSR pour
les patients qui sont hospitalisés un
hôpital des jours pour les patients qui
sont au domicile et peuvent bénéficier
d'une prise en charge euh dans cet
hôpital et aussi les accueils des jours
qui c'est une structure qui va aussi
permettre de prolonger la prise en
charge de ces patients qui sont euh dans
un état évoluer de la pathologie selon
un sondage réalisé par France Alzheimer
près de 80 % des aidents rencontrent des
difficultés à associer leur vie
professionnel et leur activité
d'accompagnement